My name is
Fife and Aoi, and we
are holding a guide to the Tokyo metropolitan area in Ginza, Tokyo. c
In Tokyo, we would like to introduce you to the dignity of samurai, their behavior,
and how to use the katana.
[Music]  The
Katagi family doesn't remember how to settle a grudge, because there was a samurai who was in a battle during the summer, taking pictures with
chestnuts, using a sword
when he moved, and using chopsticks when facing an enemy.  I walk
slowly,
rubbing my feet against the ground, never walking or sienna.By doing
this, my
hips don't wobble, and I
can see my force and coercive force against the target.
So, what is a
nukuchi? The
moment the enemy attacks you, you
open it on the hilt of your sword and
cut it at the same time as you take it off. This is called a nukuchi. It's a
Kishu technique. The
battle begins.
4th part is also very good.
And lastly.  The Seigan stance key
is also the most basic stance.The upper stance from this basic stance to the attack is called
Higa Mae.  When in a stance, there is no room for
chance.In this way, the temperature
decreases from the Seigan stance at first.The
samurai's heart is filled with novelty, and he calmly lowers the
tip of his sword.  Cutting downwards from the bottom to the top is
rounded up.
[Applause]
[Music]
On the other hand, cutting diagonally from the top to the bottom is
called Kesagiri.
In that sense, that's
good, Dad.  The
samurai is a star.
All the samurai have swords. As the dojo says, they have
two arranged swords. At
home, I have a short sword, and the short one, like me, is holding
this short sword.
When it comes to the back from the late type for alternative, the car that you always have and the car that you always have,
and this person is always
rude and rude,
you always
say Haraoka cold.  I'm
serious about this.
Samurai in the old days
created a samurai. It's not just
those who kill swordsmen, but those who
discipline themselves, protect their families, and protect their teeth. This
person is kind for the sake of world peace.  When
using a wooden sword, people used to
carry wooden swords around the end of the Edo period.That's because they were
made of oak wood.I've heard a lot about the
Samurai's movement manual, Metsuke,
and the fact that it was used to kill people is amazing.5  I
liked it,
and if you become a samurai when you're 6 years old or older, you'll have parental rights removed.So,
in this scene, I
went to math class.It's a
normal,
pretty good movement.It's a movement that no one would drink as a samurai.  You
're preparing for the enemy's attack,
and
then you're stepping back in order to take advantage of the attack.This
is similar to how a samurai moves.That's
good.Well
, the thread is the enemy.  If you are too far away in the field of battle, you will
not be able to
do it.If you are too close, you will not be able to do it.The distance at which you can kill the opponent with the best movement is called the distance.The
terrain is similar to the samurai's basement.In
order to perform this movement.  It
's a movement that can only be done with a lot of training.
25th and 3rd place
It's the sky, it's a
death, and the people who came have many voices, and it
's a movement that can't be done without a moment. It's
amazing. It's
a year that can only be done on the wall.  I think it's great that things have changed for the better. It's said that
fighting with Randi was more common in times of narrow love.
However, he withstood this wakizashi, and the wakizashi
was a samurai's stabbing from the Japanese side.  The
long one is a short sword, and the
right-release sword is
called a sign.The reason why it is
used in Japan is that the waki lace is used as a spare in case the longer sword is turned,
and it is
narrow.  When fighting in a room, the signs are more effective.In a
fight with an enemy, it
is normally better to use the following signs, but if the long side becomes a hindrance in a narrow room,
use the short side in that sense.Use
all your energy.  You can see that he is using his opponent for a glance. The
battle between No. 22 and Nonshi has
begun again. The
sword can cut and build, and the
moon is difficult to use, especially if it is a short one.  This means that there is an effective way
to attack,
and then the
opponent's Soap Senta A
sword is
opened to create an opening.
By lowering the sword from the top to the bottom, the fingers
fall, so
this means that a good fight is likely to occur during the reform period.  It's been proven,
Bach, that
when you use a sword, you stand on a heavy foot and your
body collapses under the sea of ​​swords.In order to
support it, you lower your back, bend your knees, and
then use your
legs.  I don't want to keep thinking about it while it's on. By
swinging the sword in this way, I
can stop the weight of the sword.
And if I don't have the strength, I can't wait for the
new sword exchange. I'm so excited on the road.  It's
really well made.
And if you
pull out this plastic blood vessel that I've made and receive it,
e 7
[Music] You
can wear the soft cloth from above, but you can put it on the side.
Living horizontally and beautifully
can only be done by someone who is an expert at something.They
can cut hard things very well.For example, they can cut soft things
like today's ren, which have n no hanging down, and are worn from top to bottom.  It's
easy to cut.
However,
when you cut a soft material from side to side, from left to right, the
fabric escapes. Cutting through it requires speed,
and you have to fit it perfectly in order to cut it.
In this video, it's perfect.  Ah, the way it disappears horizontally and at right angles in the corridor is amazing.
[Music] I
saw this movie 58 years ago when I was 16 years old, and
it was the movie that moved me the most.
Now, Mr.
Tanba's samurai
changes his name to
make sure he
doesn't let his guard down.The enemy says
Hana, so he uses his name to lure him in, and uses a stance that he doesn't normally use.
By taking a stance, the
usage of the face changes depending on who the opponent is.
And when I saw this work in ``Star Sorrow and Destruction'', it
may have been because I felt the heart of a
samurai.  One of the ways to fight in a small space is to fight in the
same room as the other party,
and it
is very difficult to attack the attacking troupe by leaving empty seats in front and cutting in order, and having to fight twice.  Now that you're using it, the last thing you need to do is move the
opponent's leader with a
sword or something, and the
pawn is carried with the tax applied interest rate.It's
difficult to use a sword that pushes out the blade.  In the next battle, it was just a man, and he
probably changed his sword from one to the next to avoid a box volley.If the blade spilled, it would
become like a saw, and if you couldn't cut it properly, the
moon would last for a moment.  Nihe, I'm
dying.
This is probably where I lost my heart.
And while I'm only half my body, I'm taking care of myself, and I
pick up the sword like an enemy or a pistol, and push it away. Hey, it's the
man who picks up the sword.  Both monks and monks must
be masters like this.There are
many times in Japan, and there is a
thing called haseji on the beach, and
Abe Baha's members use pipes to cleanse themselves, and
those who are taxed are treated as samurai.  I don't say it's good, but I don't think it's called a
mission. They
fight alongside their husbands.
In the Sengoku period,
samurai and their husbands
sat outside in a tatami. In the
case of women, they fought alongside their husbands.  It is also a compulsion to protect the home and the family castle, and if by any chance a
bystander comes to the mansion, it is necessary to confront them with something strong.In the event that a bystander comes to the mansion, they are
taught to confront them with something strong.
In a sense, women and families have the
same heart as the samurai, depending on the content.The
ripples disappeared on the
4th.  When a
god resides in a sword,
there is a sword in the back,
and then there is hair in the color.From the shimenawa rope to the
other side is the divine hospital.The
foreground is the second line of the sequel.He
creates a Japanese sword with the utmost of his heart.This is a good
thing.  It's the
version that shows the most braces when it comes to the way it's worn.
Earthquake Tackle Berry is overwhelming. It's probably Kazuo's good fortune that the
opponent is probably a different person because of his behavior. He's
probably willing to buy the kimono.  That's right, it's a country. It's not
going to disappear. Yes, that's all. 5 If you say so, you'll think about it on the west bank. When you
change your stance, you ca
n't do the ceremony by
moving quickly. However, by moving quickly, you
can get hit in the split second when the sword returns to its original position.  However, it is
different in the case of team competitions.If you exchange responses and the mood becomes 1 person, 2 people, 3 people, 4 people, you
must immediately take action toward the target.Move quickly and
listen to the target.  So there is a slight difference between the individual one-time competition, the challenge, and the eyepatch brainwashing battle.In
this case, we talked about it being one-on-one.There are a lot of things.The way you hold your stance, the
sensing style comes out.You
open your body halfway,
and  Mello
moves his body diagonally. Well, that's called a half-body.
When he moves forward, his back falls to Getty this morning.
Yeah, I think it was a good fight. Aaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaa... I've been trying to get into the
zone.  This
is where you stand up against the residents of the baking kiln.
Tobidobu Pistol When you eat and meet the opponent, if you go straight ahead, you will go outside again, so
this is the best way to move from side to side.
And for the mellow, this is also a projectile.  When it comes to holding, the
samurai ronin brought out
a knife that was used as a shuriken.The
idea of ​​using a chikusa on the opponent's arm even though he has the right to collect is amazing.I
remembered this when I saw this a long time ago.He
used this knife as a shuriken.
Or rather, if you're a
person, the
yakuza people are not trained to handle the sword,
so you can't do it easily.  It
's a rule on the third floor that nothing happens.
2Yamada-san
2 I
said crest.It's the
mark here.It's called a family crest.Even if you're a ronin who
rises in the family rank, you should listen to this crest and wear a hakama.  I think it's because of one's own
meritorious deeds
and leading the way.These
two Jimbo black crests are probably caused by an
error, but while wearing a crest with good eyesight, it seems to be a bit smudged.
When we fight
[Music]
Ronin
gaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaa,
when I enter the dojo, I
have a lot of time.Why does it
cost 0 in the dojo?How do you have a divine face?  I'm told that it's a
sacred place, a place used for battle, and
so
on.Actually, it's a place where people are created, but it's out.There are
shrines in those places,
and it's a form of a company that masters humanity.Th
I can
easily do this.  It's
not about the shape, but it's like a carriage that hits you.
However, it's
very difficult to
stop the sword just when you're aiming at a. If you stop at the point where you aim, you wouldn't draw your
sword out of nowhere.  There are times when you can't help
but kill your opponent.This
time, if this young samurai can't do it, he won't be able to do it, so he won't be able to do it.Today, if he can be
defeated, he can do it by using the fullness of throwing, but in reality.  Yes, I
felt like I was able to play Matsue, which I think would be quite difficult to say.Hmm,
in that sense, it
was good.